you couldn't come on a better day I mean
we have I'm not gonna call it global
chaos going on but I'll call it a global
uncertainty and we've got the emergency
rate cut in the u.s. 50 basis points
yesterday so uh thanks for coming
because I've been kind of high I feel
like this is your Super Bowl and now
here you are all right so retweet first
everyone who's on Twitter watching this
we're live-streaming please retweet this
like favorite comment do whatever it
takes to make sure that everyone does
can watch this this is gonna be a really
really big episode I'm just giving Raul
kind of calling a lot of this situation
all right so let's for those that don't
know you that the small few let's start
with just kind of quick to three minutes
on your background and kind of what
gives you the perspective that you have
for kind of these types of events yeah
so my background is I started in the
finance industry back in 1990 straight
into a recession scrambled around to get
a job couldn't get a job at an
investment bank had a pretty shitty
degree and so I got into a company
called Dow Jones telerate which the
information provider and my first job
was custom support teaching people know
helping people that with a technical
analysis product so I had to learn what
technical analysis was because that's
trained these guys I didn't know
anything about them about it so I
started learning about technical
analysis and realize that okay that was
quite interesting I could figure out
what was going on in financial markets
with a few charts then I might have
talked my way into company called James
Capel which was pop HSBC in equity
derivatives and six months later I was
running the desk then I went to another
UK bank and end up at Goldman where I
started and managed the hedge fund sales
business in equities knackery
derivatives right in line for the Asian
crisis which was a incredible moment in
time then after that
I thought that the recession was coming
in 2000 and I thought the better
opportunity was to go to trade instead
so I went to the started the global
macro fund for the biggest hedge fund
firm in Europe at the time called GOG
Partners got that recession traded all
that whole period and then decided to
opt out of the rat race and retire to
Spain back in 2005 I started writing
macroeconomic investment strategy
research because I've been in the hedge
fund and around the hedge fund industry
for longer than most people you know my
entire career was speaking to the most
famous hedge fund managers in the world
on a daily basis whether it's Paul Tudor
Jones Stan Druckenmiller there's bacon
all of these guys so I get some learn
how they did things I saw almost every
trade every one of these guys did over
the Asian crisis which is phenomenal
because then I really understood how
they put together a macro view and just
to see them implement trades in
different ways and across continents
across asset classes and layer into it
all of that stuff with fascinating the
whole thing was reading like a picture
for me it's basically a crash course in
what are the richest most successful
people in the world do when everyone
else is running here's how these guys
are navigating these markets and how
they're profiting in many cases yeah
this stuff happens yeah because they
actually counter to the narrative the
really big money is to be made at cycle
turning points and the most money of all
is the down cycle and the reason is is
because the up cycle can take ten years
like we just had and the down cycle
usually comes in 18 months
so the compressed amount of returns that
you can get if you can short things or
take advantage of that move up in bonds
for example is truly extraordinary so I
asked mark usko who obviously know
pretty well one time I said what
separates the top five investors in each
asset class from the really really good
one so kind of the absolute best at
their craft versus everyone else and
what he said to me is they cut their
losers faster than everyone else and
they press the winners harder than every
two and I don't agree you don't agree of
that why because people like Nick rad DT
people don't know he's below the radar
screen was probably the greatest macro
trader of all time
he didn't do that okay he had enormous
stomach for risk what he had was his he
had behaviors a he had better
understanding in his head of the
outcomes and therefore he could have
ascertained the risk reward so he would
suffer more significant drawdowns than
anybody else could suffer but he would
make higher return so he made more
return to the stand Druckenmiller more
returns than george soros really at when
he was working for soros Wow
most people don't realize that but in
general speaking for most people most
people don't have that skill set of
course you know so generally speaking
cut your losses run your winners of
course that's and that's a very flippant
saying because actually not that easy to
do yeah of course it's actually
difficult not to cut your winners what
what is your current portfolio look like
just so as we get into these people kind
understand how you're actually
allocating your capital yeah so my
personal capital is allocated to bonds I
got close some of the position recently
it is dollars it is gold and it's
Bitcoin it's a pretty defensive
portfolio and I don't think of in those
terms I think of what I'm thinking of
his bonds I think you can make
extraordinaire and money and I've
written about Twitter on Twitter and I
retweeted recently about the greatest
trader ever saw it happened in 2001 when
I was trading and how similar the setup
was to today explain that story that
story is a story of a guy working for a
giant hedge fund in London and
the Fed cut and almost identical that
backdrop to today - the virus right so
we were going to economic slowdown it
was pretty clear the Fed had to cut the
markets the bond market starts pricing
and fed cuts so the Fed then do a cut on
I think it was January the 3rd everyone
on holiday but this guy comes into the
office of this hedge fund outside London
and he goes limit long according to his
risk guidelines Eurodollar futures
expiring that year Eurodollar futures
are interest rate three-month interest
rate futures so he was betting that
interest rates were gonna get cut
significantly and he gets on a plane and
he goes to his house in Majorca and
stays there and because he can't take
any more risk he's got one trade off and
his view is we're going to recession the
stock market is in a bubble the Fed are
gonna have to cut significantly and the
Alps the downside of the stock market
bubble unwinding is the economy goes
into recession that was cool
so he didn't come back to the office and
eventually there was a pickup in rates
as people started fading that narrative
and thinking growth was coming back
which is exactly whether we got in
September October November the ship's
exactly the same in fact the both charts
map each other perfectly the most
perfect maps I've ever seen is now
versus then so his boss one of the most
famous hedge fund managers in the world
one of the best risk takers all-time
calls him in and goes so you've given
back a load of money you've made more
money than any other trader of the firm
but you've given back a lot what do you
want to do they said I want to double up
really
and the guy said why he goes because my
case is still valid and I've got profits
and it's my risk to run and the guy said
fine do it because he understood that
the guy had the clarity there's that
moment in time when you have the clarity
and he had the clarity and he went back
to me Orca and the reason I was in
Majorca was simple is he didn't want a
way to call him his friends to call him
or anybody to persuade you to get out of
the trade yep and he then returned in
November close the trade and retired do
we know what the return was he made I
believe for himself two hundred million
two hundred million it's not a bad day
but again I don't know quite the numbers
and I won't mention his name because he
had a private guy but phenomenal and
that was one trade one trade ad close
that was it
when you look at that trade - today is
the same opportunity available
we've just had it so it's been tweeting
and talking and shouting and screaming
to everybody about this because there's
a moment in time when look this part of
the cycle is what I do I'm really good
at this doesn't mean I'm always right as
a minumum [ __ ] but I'm good at this
and I knew that the cycle was turning
and we had a shot in 2016 when we had a
almost a recession we had the
manufacturing recession but it didn't
follow through but this time looked like
the stars were aligned and I think we're
going to cut so I started that whole
thing by May with the Eurodollar futures
and then by August I was pounding the
table and screaming and shouting I
remember and then it basically kept -
ever since
so we just went through a emergency 50
basis point rate cut I saw a guy on top
of she I forget his name yesterday
literally saying in the next two weeks
we could be at zero which seems a little
aggressive where do we go from here
well look we were pricing in a recession
and now we're pricing something else so
it's gone faster than we've expected so
this is and that's because your argument
is the economic kind of
a crow situation was slowing everything
you'd been talking about it was going to
be a recession coming right Global
creates our rent you get an accelerant
with the krona four we had to
accelerants right so we had the Fed
raising rates back in 2017 and they've
gone too far
so you saw it because you start seeing
the curve inverting start see all of
this signs that the federal on too far
which was extraordinary because they
barely raise rates but that was the
situation so that was the slowdown that
was set then we had trade war it's a
trade war and tariffs that was the
kindling for the recession so that's the
recession we were gonna get and then the
coronavirus comes and now we're gonna
get something entirely different
where do you think we're going right if
we're not yet if we're not getting a
recession what is it you know the answer
that's what you're asking
so listen the reason why I'm so excited
to have you here is because you have
become you know what a storm chaser is
like a tornado chaser right well yeah
they go and they try to find the
tornadoes and they're the the psychos
that are driving on the road and they're
filming the tornado to me you're a
crisis chaser right meaning that it's
not that you want a crisis tactics a lot
of people get hurt and it's really bad
situation but you have the clarity to
see them coming and we've also lived
calls and I'm seeing them before and I
know
so the point bigger the crisis chaser
yeah the point being is it's about human
behavior it's not about what's right
what's wrong and it's not about
how you should interpret the numbers rot
nothing it's like when it comes to a
crisis whether it was the Asian crisis
whether it was the bond market crisis in
94 the Asian crisis in 97 the dot-com
bust or the banking crisis they're all
human behavior and once you understand
that humans are about to panic it's when
everything moves fast yeah and I think
that if you are a good investor you
actually slow down right you you you
don't have to get caught up in that
panic it's like having the emotional
defense then we see really what I did in
this situation and I did in all the
other situations was I doubled up ahead
of the panic when I saw that it was
likely to lead to a panic because my job
is not to live in at present it's
everybody makes the mistake of living in
the present saying oh the virus numbers
today are X that is not what you're
doing you have to extrapolate and you
have to think of possible futures of
which you don't know there are no
certainties
but it's extrapolating positive futures
when you see a path of events that
little seems much more probable than the
market expects and you can see a clear
understanding of how people are going to
react to that then you have something
really meaty with this situation it was
clear that the moment the virus spread
outside sure it was clear that China had
gone into total shutdown
okay that was we've never seen that in
our lifetimes anywhere in any country so
this isn't this is import look let's
talk about exactly oh that's a lot to
talk about so there's a virus the
Chinese government gets wind of hey this
is spreading this is a problem and
there's a couple of different ways to
look at how they've reacted there's the
kind of medical reaction so this is
where you see quarantines and and a
building of hospitals and Wrekin stuff
but the economic impact of a lot of this
is literally they just went into
complete shutdown nobody go anywhere do
and yes so the idea is if you've got a
really bad outbreak of a unknown virus
you can either take the risk and have
mass death
even with a death rate the w-h-o two
days say it's three and a half percent
so with a population size of China's and
it's an aging population and it affects
old people more that is too much for the
government to deal with and you have
unknowns cuz you don't know the death
rates at that point you don't know the
spread great what they clearly knew is
spreading fast very fast so I think
what's known as the RO or the R was
above anything from the common flu to
the Spanish flu to any of the known
pandemics so they knew that it was
extremely dangerous hence why you go to
the carnival ama clock down which is to
quarantine that Pop's parts of the
population because the weird part of
this virus is it's not detectable for
two weeks and up to 27 days so we can
all have it here and we have no symptoms
and we're spreading it around and we
don't know right that is like a nuclear
[ __ ] warhead right you have no idea
you have one of the fastest spreading
viruses we know of and it's undetectable
and it has a high death rate even though
people say oh that's not a very high
death rate when you actually impute the
numbers that it's a staggering number of
people that could die but the numbers
that I looked at this morning basically
anyway I think is 1840 or something was
the bucket that they showed the flu
death rate is point O two percent and
the coronavirus death rate is point two
so literally at n acts now it's still 20
basis points yeah but when you start to
look at that and again it's still scary
don't think about the death rate because
everyone will say well it's not that
relevant isn't 2% or three and a half
percent and only affects old people's
not gonna fit me there's no economic
impact it it's the fact that when you
acute the numbers that it spreads faster
than Spanish people let's assume it
reached the same number of people as a
Spanish flu let's assume nobody
quarantines countries like China which
was the right thing today
then Spanish flu hit 27 percent of the
entire worlds population and at the time
that meant 500 million people were
infected and in the end about 30 million
people died
okay if you look at 27% of the
population now it's about two billion
people if you have a death rate three
and a half percent 68 million people
will die
so that's your base worst case scenario
so then that's what you have what that's
the outcome if you don't do anything so
every government is going to do
everything they can because also it
disproportionately affects Western
developed nations why because your old
populations all of us right so you have
a significant problem also old
populations who get a virus I mean the
death rate of people go into hospital is
huge in this virus and there's a large
number people Afghan hospital we have no
ability to deal with this in the medical
system so they have no choice but to
start coronating nations or at least
large regions which has a ridiculous
economic impact in terms of the slowdown
the number like talking a little bit
about the numbers that came out of China
the yuck I mean China car sales fell 92
percent and this month they're down 80
something percent we well my god that's
[ __ ] wild but I mean the PMI the
Purchasing Managers Index for for China
had the largest fall I've ever seen in
any economic statistic I've ever seen
and that is in the second largest
economy on earth with the largest
population it is mind blowing and no
wonder the oil prices collapse no wonder
all of these things are happening and
that's just China the point being to all
of this is next it was South Korea South
Korea is a great medical system and they
were on top of it fast they're slowing
the rate of the virus there but they
still got thousands of people affected
and the death rates climb and it's not
going to go and then it spread
regionally but then the next big cluster
was Italy Italy exploded it's still
going because they're still I mean this
bloody flights every 10 minutes from
malpensa and
are you crazy it's now exploding in
Spain France Germany Iran if Iran was a
truly extraordinary cuz it was a
different strain they didn't know that
it come from China whether it had come
from China and it I mean literally 10%
of all government officials are infected
fifty percent or 20 percent of the
entire government is ill so crazy so
back that out to what is about to happen
right what's interesting is South Korea
is testing thousands of people a day to
get on top of where it is where it's
moving what we have to who we need
quarantine the u.s. up until last Friday
had tested 500 people and they had only
tested people that had come from China
or Japan or a country that had the virus
and I think this is where we get
Washington State there was the outbreak
and kind of a whole group of people have
now tested positive they all are
circulating either they worked at our
patients at or or I guess live at this
nursing home and I was reading this
morning that in Wake County North
Carolina actually where I'm from there's
a coronavirus confirmation case and you
start reading about well how the hell
does that happen the person went and
literally went to that nursing home a
couple of weeks ago comes back to the
point being a couple of weeks ago mm-hmm
right so this it's very clear that the
corona virus has been spreading
undetected and unabated in the United
States for at least three weeks
there was a weird ridiculous situation
where the CDC and the FDA gotten some
regulatory mess where it got declared a
national emergency which meant that the
only the CDC could do testing with CDC
approved equipment of which it was only
one place in Atlanta to do it they
eventually got it out to 40 different
places eventually but no testing went
ahead because the kits were not approved
and there were some malfunctions with
the kid so there's been no testing in
America so nurses and doctors and health
care workers have been treating people
without taking precautions
there is no tracking of pneumonia cases
yet because they're usually now they're
most likely to be corona virus cases so
the point being is when you look forward
and Boris Johnson was good yesterday in
the UK when he said listen 80 percent of
the population could get this you know
and this is going to be huge and we're
gonna have to we may have to shut down
the entire country and he's right to get
the narrative that far that fast to get
people to understand the seriousness of
it because in the u.s. people don't even
understand this they're still going it's
the flu no it's not the flu the size of
it and speed the speed at which it
spreads and the incremental increase in
deaths worldwide is not something a
government will take so they're going to
have to close large parts of the economy
and people nobody's going to fly them
this will be the last flyer takers the
flight go back to the Cayman Islands and
I think the Cayman Islands will shut and
I've already been speaking to up here
some of the doctors there Bravo blog we
haven't any cases yet but they know it's
gonna shut yeah so when that happens if
it's not a recession if it's something
worse yeah so it look the clear thing is
we were going to a recession could have
been a mild one could have been a big
one we don't really know where we're
going to recession this just pressed the
nuclear button for depression now I say
that not lightly there is always a
probability that it doesn't happen but
it's become my base case now because I
do not see a world in which there is not
an outcome that I have to
down whole parts of economies whether
that's travel tourism conferences
businesses all of this stuff already
seeing it it's already starting to
happen right we're seeing conferences
get cancelled we're seeing obvious
slowdowns in travel and tourism weight
when they corn some people at home you
know it's not long before you guys are
gonna be at home doing this self
quarantined it's gonna happen because
you're going to want to do that for your
own sake and you don't to be part of the
spread of the virus you know because
it's gonna be your mother or grandmother
that gets killed so your argument here
is the virus itself is simply an
accelerant on a situation that was
already turning bad right in the
economic kind of recessionary period and
now what we're gonna do is were actually
going to extend that into an actual
depression and really it's again I don't
deal in certainties but I'm saying that
the the probability the highest
probability event now is a much larger
event and I think potentially my base
case is for coming and we have to see
over the next four weeks my base case is
coming that this will be the worst
economic event of our lifetimes so this
is much larger than 2008 so let's hold
that as the highest probability outcome
yeah let's switch to what the hell do
people do if you're alright right if
that actually occurs well at what level
are we talking now
are we talking personally investment or
what so let's focus on the investment
side we could the personal side there's
plenty of information out there but up
from the investment seat what do people
do in terms of one preparing for this
and then two if it actually occurs how
do they act or or think through the
various opportunities that present them
to let's ignore profiting from it for
now we come back to trading it that's a
different thing the average person
there's gonna be a lot of job losses
just because companies will not be able
to fort it this government's gonna have
to try and support companies they're
doing that in China there is going to be
so you've got a significant chance of
job losses that's the main thing you
have a significant chance of metalic
medical expenses the United States which
is a big problem of the system here so
it is an economic event for most
households and a significant economic
event are you ready for that and that
means and one of the best piece of
advice I was ever given was given back
to me in 1991 which was he who has cash
in a recession is king I like to say he
who has cash makes the rules Yeah right
but the point being is whatever you do
just have some cash on hand this is not
a financial event where we have to worry
about the banks sure it might morph into
something and I'm not making predictions
on that but just have some cash because
just make sure you've got the
availability to deal with this and maybe
I'm wrong what have you lost
nothing but what are you what are you
you're more prepared so that's and you
know and I've been and it won't be many
of the viewers or listeners to this but
if you are approaching retirement I've
again at real vision we've done this
screamed and shouted about the
allocation people have in their pensions
they are taking too much risk hoping to
breach that magic number well if I am
right then the downside is enormous and
it won't recover for a significant
period of time over which period people
are going to get laid off or retires so
in which case they don't get to buy the
dip so you have too much equity you have
too much credit and you've never earned
enough bonds because you've always
thought bond yields of 1% aren't worth
it well this is why you learn that bonds
are the greatest thing on earth so
you've been long bonds yeah
obviously done very well there yeah
we've seen Treasury yields go to very
low levels walk us through kind of your
current view of the bonds and in light
of the Treasury yield movement yes I
have been hoping for a sharp pull back
there'll be a point where you get this
gut check that usually happens in the
middle of these and again listen from
experience of trading these you get a
movement against today because the
central bank's announce something and if
one thinks it's going to be safe you
have to look through that and say well
what are the central bank's going to do
to this situation nothing there's
nothing they can do all they're doing is
showing the receipts of the recovery in
due course that's what central banks do
and so any opportunity to buy bonds you
buy bonds because rates are going to
zero everywhere and they're propagating
negative now everyone goes negative
bonds never gonna happen you tell me
that when I stock markets down 50
percent and all the other assets are
falling and the credit markets blowing
up I'll pay two percent all day to have
my money back people don't understand
the value of getting your money back
versus the interest rate and it's the
value of getting your money back that's
so important so I think bonds will go
negative and they're negative all around
the world and have been for years now
and that hasn't blown up it's a it's a
death of the banking system over time
but it's not an instant nuke button is
it fair to say that you look at bonds in
this kind of depression Airy type
environment if that occurs as the best
opportunity was part of the worst
opportunities but they're a call option
because right the Fed Arkana raise rates
so bonds aren't gonna move against you
and thinking in price terms if all hell
breaks loose
you'll get your money back in bonds but
if all hell breaks loose and the bond
price rallies which it will do
you'll make a [ __ ] ton so it basically
looks like a call option in environment
like this this is why people might stand
Druckenmiller makes all his money from
euro dollars and bonds because if they
have such a skewed risk reward also
equities move around
around human behavior there's no
anchoring to equities you know that's
why valuations go up and down Eurodollar
futures are anchored by the interest
rate yeah they can move a little bit
away from where the Fed Funds rate is or
whatever so basically they have to
reflect economic truths one whale the
other thing get better the head of the
truth or behind they can get it wrong
get it right but generally over time
they have to follow what be where the
interest rates are the long bond is
basically that plus future inflation
that's it so you have a clean macro
variable to aim for so if you're just
forecasting where rates are going you
can trade your own dollars if I say
rates are going to zero what you should
be saying is Ralph thinks your dollars
going to a hundred and therefore they're
currently trying to get 98 99 40
therefore there's not as 60 ticks upside
therefore can i buy the calls will it
you know that's how everybody thinks
when you think of euro dollars and I've
spent the best part of a year trying to
educate people about bonds because the
narrative driven by the investment
industry is bonds bad equities good and
it's wrong because and and
when you look at in price appreciation
terms bonds are pretty much outperformed
equities over the long run for a very
long time now because in price
appreciation terms they're so phenomenal
but the little trick
the little hoodwink from the asset
managers firms is a look at the yield
well that's like just saying equities
dividend yield no it's the price and the
price appreciation on bonds has been
truly extraordinary as this massive
demographic wave of people the baby
boomers has come through and dampened
inflation and dampen growth means the
bond yields are bombs have exploded and
bond yields are forward you think that
I'll continue yes got it how do you
think about like that bond bond position
that you have taking profits doubling up
just kind of arrest Lee you're correct
yes when you doubled up and went kind of
max limit long and that's also the
advice that I gave to in global back an
investor which is their kind of home
research service and also in the kind of
real vision Pro stuff so I just said
listen this is the time to take the
maximum risk because I know the
narrative or know where it's going to
see this before everyone's going to
panic be ahead of the panic and make
money for it so now we're in the middle
of that where the narrative is caught up
with the reality right you didn't shake
my hand when we walk in right so that's
narrative reality meeting it not because
I don't like you just you know no but I
read from the CDC I'm not supposed to
share I've got my hand sanitizer right
so so that is the narrative catching up
with with weather market sauce
we've got the cut which is what the bum
mark it was after as well the bond
market is telling us we're gonna get
another cut at the Fed meeting so the
Fed will go a hundred then I love it on
Twitter now because you can see where
the narrative is that out of is oh my
god the Fed they're idiots they're
cutting wise how's this gonna help what
they're not understanding is what the
forward narrative is the forward
narrative is this is not recession this
is a potential depression you have to do
anything you can do to stop that
happening and secondly if you understand
that
the u.s. is about to start testing for
Coronas virus in larger numbers over the
next four weeks we're going to go from
whatever we are today 100 and some in
cases or turn of cases and we're gonna
go to 2,000 and we're going to go to
10,000 at an unbelievable rate and in an
election year
you are incentivized to panic as a state
local authority government everybody
sitting like war right is any time that
you can be the one in charge in a time
of chaos panic uncertainty etc there's a
higher likelihood that you will stay in
office because the transition scares
people right yes although I do think
that Trump made and it's too early win
the election but to understand what's
going on we don't even know whether it's
gonna be buying us arms or whatever but
Trump made a very bad error by the
political era was was you know getting
rid of half the CDC okay fine whatever
that's politics when he had to stand up
in front of the nation and say we've got
a problem like Boris Johnson just did
and I don't like Boris Johnson but I was
pretty impressed with him saying what he
said except for he said he went to the
hospital took everyone's hand he's fine
because he's because he's an idiot but
good but you know he's an idiot for
saying it as well yeah yeah you know
because if that was the moment people
did with HIV it's like this is not the
same as HIV this spreads by hand yeah
and so Trump didn't say anything apart
I'm gonna put my pencil look at it it's
not really important he they spread the
fruit flu narrative that still won't die
down
and that was irresponsible because if we
find out that in six weeks time we've
got 50,000 cases then all hell is gonna
break loose and because of the freedom
of travel is still going on in the
United States it is not in not small
probability let's talk a little bit
about the impact of coronavirus on kind
of the corporate debt situation right so
great question so one of the things that
I saw in China I was reading that these
Chinese companies are levered to the
[ __ ] head with all this debt if
there's an economic slowdown even a
little stalling of the economy all of a
sudden they can't pay the debt you have
to have the government a bank somebody
has to step in there's all kinds of
ramifications how do you look at that
let's start with the US and then maybe
cool look so step back from a macro
perspective define the bubble that the
biggest part of the bubble that were in
now it's the corporate debt bubble okay
there is a mechanism behind that that is
very important to people to understand
so where does this debt come from comes
from American companies issuing their
what are they issuing debt they issuing
debt to buy back their own shares it's
an accounting trick and to make it worse
they're issuing selves' the management
team stock options then they at the at
the board they then say right and how
many shares should we bite back today
guess what if you're removing the number
of shares your share price goes up in
normal circumstances so they're making
themselves rich by basically raping the
shareholders the shareholders have an
optical illusion because the price is
going up but actually all these
corporations taking more and more debt
iBM has been a classic example of that
so that's that mechanism of where the
debt comes from
now the buyer of that day is the pension
system because there's bunch of these
poor baby boomers getting close to a
time and you don't have enough savings
so they look for any yield they can so
corporate debt has a bit more yield than
government bonds and it's deemed safe so
we'll just buy as much of that as you
can give us and that is being driven by
all these pensions didn't have enough
returns over the last 40 50 years so
they the states the state pensions the
states have raised taxes and are putting
the tax money into these pensions and
that tax money is it comes in every
month other people's wages buys these
corporate bonds so you got this lovely
environment where these 1% are getting
extremely rich the corporations are
issuing more and more debt and buying
back their shares they are the only
buyer of equities if you look on
aggregate almost everybody else is a net
divestiture of equities in the world
there's a bit of foreign buying that's
it the entire pension system is trying
to divest of equities but it's still
switching to credit but as every baby
boomer leaves the workforce that
eventually starts yep moving out so the
entire worlds and net seller of equities
but the corporations are the buyers and
we've just had one of the biggest stock
market bubbles of all time then on the
other side we've had the biggest credit
bubble of all time corporations are now
because of this ridiculous tax rule are
now corporate debts GDP the house has
ever been in history and the issue is is
there is only one bar of that credit
which is a pension system really because
even we yields are too low for half of
insurance companies up but let's say
it's insurance companies and these
pension companies when you go into
recession or just the business cycle
goes negative just a normal one forget
the depression scenario just a normal
recession there's a company your cash
flows go negative and your earnings go
negative right it's standard pretty
obvious yeah
well that means you stop buying back
your shares because you don't have the
cash flow to buy your shares so that
means that the moment you go into
recession which is where we're going now
just when you need it the most in
illiquid markets the world's largest
power of equities leaves and there are
no baby boomers buying equities
there's no Millennials buying it there's
nobody to offset this would it be fair
to say there that the structure you just
don't know let me finish the other side
of the structure the other side of the
structure is tax receipts are driven by
the business cycle so when taxes REITs
go negative when the business cycle goes
negative and therefore there's no buying
in these state pensions of the corporate
debt either so what you have is at the
very same time as soon as the business
cycle goes negative give it a you know a
month or two of lag basically the bar of
credit leaves the bar of equity leaves
and there's no buyers at the same time
you have this huge amount of these
triple B credits which are huge old
companies that have issued so much debt
that they've been downgraded and
downgraded that could get knocked into
junk if they get not into junk status
they will leave these credit portfolios
and have to go and jump on pokefloats
problem this is four trillion of these
bonds so the numbers are too big for the
junk bond market to absorb so the
john-mark junk bond market will just
basically seize up and to accommodate it
yields will have to explode
when there's no buyer I need to get that
across
there is no buyer of this stuff and
there is no viral vector which means
that the share price of General Electric
Ford and all of these triple B's get
pummeled which increases the chance of a
downgrade which increases the chance of
them dipping
so what you've got I call it the Doom
loop and I feel like we're just about to
set that off and credit is the next big
thing so this structure that you just
described how we've kind of gotten here
there's two key components to it the
first is the 1% got really really rich
during this run we have seen an
explosion of CEOs and c-suite executives
walking through the door they're leaving
yeah and they're not leaving because
they think it's gonna get a better
situation they've kind of made a lot of
money and now seem to be a good time
even to the point of seeing somebody
like a bob iger do it overnight
effective immediately
right this isn't a hey I'm gonna leave
in six months or in a year this is I was
gonna leave you know in a year or two
now I'm leaving today is that what it
looks like is it that these executives
understand kind of the situation you're
describing and it's always better to
leave at the top kind of walk out with
the championship trophy then then wait
till it's a bad situation yes and I was
just chatting to a friend of mine last
night he's just sold his business is an
investment banking business
he's just sold it now why is he held it
on for ten years why does he just sell
it now another friend of mine sold his
audio-visual business why now and it's
because they kind of know time now's a
good time look we all think we can tie
them we can but these guys kind of know
that particularly at that level of
c-suite and because it's overrun by baby
boomers so let's assume that most of
these people are 65 to 70 or 60 to 70
that's the cohort of the c-suite of
corporate America well your man's going
to retirement you just don't want to
deal with this
and and because really there's an 18 to
24 month period let's say that's a
recession or a depression right it's
really really bad for most people and
then you'll get a recovery somehow we've
seen in other situations but that
recovery just to get back to the same
level you work could take years if not
well it doesn't work if you're a retiree
so it's different if you're young if
you're young it's like okay this is
gonna be one of the war stories that you
will have like I have and come on a
podcast in 20 years time with the war
stories right that's fine but and you're
there are opportunities they'll be
opportunity to make money I think
there's a whole new financial system
coming out this and we'll get into that
later but for the baby boomers the
problem is is they can't buy the dip
because they're retiring so you're going
to let's say the average recession not
really bad one average recession lowers
share prices by about 40 percent maybe
50
well you're incentivized to sell because
you want to crystallize your losses and
I've seen this firsthand from friends of
mine and parents 2001-2008 the thing is
oh [ __ ] protect my pool I will just make
the wrong decision but I have to sell I
cannot see my money go down even less
because then I'm going to run out and be
bankrupt when I'm old if I'm bankrupt
that's at 80 years old and totally
[ __ ] so they're incentivized
behavioral incentive is I have to sell
so that is inherently built into the
system the pension system is implicitly
a short a put as well because they have
to deliver returns through retirees now
the problem is is then if they've
allocated too much to equity and they're
gonna have to pay entitlements these
people in two years time well somehow
they don't have to sell that equity to
pay that entitlement and the more yields
fall I mean let me talk about this yet
but this yield fall from two percent to
one percent basically means you need
twice as much money to live off the
yield as it goes to zero you can never
have enough money to live off yield so
you have to eat to have capital gains
that completely screws up all pension
calculations does this lead to the blow
up do we see pensions blow up in major
ways listen I've been talking about this
for a long time
everybody's gonna have to understand the
reality that their pension is not what
they think it is what does that mean
know what I mean that would things now
what did they think it is is that a your
ink it's a promise okay
and a guarantee what it's not what it it
is not that okay you will not get even
if you're a fireman or a teacher or
somebody's worked all their life and
you've been told you'll get 2/3 of your
final salary that will not happen you
may be lucky and be one of the first one
few your benefits may get cut later
we've seen it everywhere happened the
same so that promise is not real so your
dreams of retirement not our dreams in
terms of what you think and nobody's got
enough the other reality is is nobody
has enough to retire on it's the numbers
will not work unless you're one of the
1% because the if you look at the
average not the average the median baby
boom because the average is so skewed by
the ultra-rich if you look at the median
baby boomer they've got like two hundred
thousand dollars I mean they basically
we can leave the last five years mm-hmm
what does that mean poor so this is why
I'm particularly worried about this
confluence of events so going to the
recession fine then the coronavirus note
sorry let's go back going to recession
fine you've always got the kindling of
this debt issue the massive corporate
debt bubble you've got an equity market
bubble okay we can kind of deal with
that but that's like 2008 in 2001 it's
kind of a hybrid when you put the
coronavirus on top and you accelerate at
all and then you've got the pension
issues with no pensioners being able to
afford to retire and think what that
does to GDP coming out of a recession it
never recovers and nor does the stock
market because there's no bar so we go
into a very different world now can we
again extrapolate more concerning events
to the financial system and the end of
this you know how to insurance company
survive the medical insurance stuff
after that what happens and the point
being is in part of this there's another
story that there's a story that I've
talked about a lot is the shortage of
dollars in the world and in this
situation that could become a problem as
well let's talk about the dollar
liquidity crisis what it mean by that
and kind of why you're concerned there's
two dollar liquidity crisis undergoing
right now okay
one is the BIS Bank of International
Settlements talked about the 15 trillion
dollars that foreigners have borrowed
the problem is is when you go into a
slowing economic cycle the world traders
in dollars world trade is currently
negative so therefore they don't have
the dollars to either pay back their
debts or service their debts and that
becomes a problem so that tends to drive
the dollar higher in periods of stress
because there's too much money there is
also a European banking system as
starved of dollars and because of
regulatory differences a dollar in the
United States and the dollar in Europe
is not the same thing they're not
fungible anymore so we had something
called the euro dollar market which is
the offshore dollar market and the
onshore funding market and they were
fungible so Deutsche Bank could have a
u.s. operation and fund its European
operations from it that stopped so
basically you got two different currency
systems which has led to the shortage of
dollars offshore which is why there's
this endless problem with the European
banking system is there's not enough
dollars to make that run because the
world actually runs on dollars and not
euros euros are a big part of it but the
dollar is what you actually need so if
you then think of the other part of this
equation is okay in a slowdown stuff
like the oil price falls well oil is
another bunch of economies that extract
things out of the ground and get paid to
u.s. dollars for them you get less
dollars so you either have to pump more
oil and what's your price fall which is
basically the shell designs you're doing
right now
the Saudis did it in 2014 and the oil
price went to 30 bucks
and the restaurant to do it again
basically the goons are flooding the
market with supply and to get dollars
that the supply-demand imbalance leads
to a lower exchange price but they are
trying to on an aggregate basis get the
same network
let's yes because let's say you have to
pay your costs of operational servicing
debt and other stuff is ten dollars a
year well and if you get it all from oil
and your income from oil is 40 dollars a
year
well if oil goes to if it all for 70%
you can't service your debts so their
incentives just sell more oils get the
the fixed number of dollars in which is
what the shell guys are doing to try and
pay their debts because they're about to
blow up
and it's the panic reaction that's what
it pumping more and more and more
because they're gonna blow up because it
goes from a premium price play to a
volume play exactly that that's exactly
the point it's a dollar at any cost
yep so so that's the that is what's
going on in the rest of the world the
Bank of England and all the central
banks have said this is a huge problem
it is uncontrolled now and they don't
know what the outcomes are this is the
rise of the central bank digital
currency because they know they have to
do something transfer mechanisms are
broken there's a whole bunch of issues
of which I don't understand but the
central banks are clearly screaming that
we need to move away not from the dollar
as our standard because there is no
other alternative yet but even as a
mechanism so I don't even quite know
what this means yet but there's
something big come we'll talk about that
later so when you're sitting there
unsure there's a funding problem as well
because everyone's at the repo borrowing
money so it's telling you there's
funding issues everywhere right now and
there's not enough dollars in the system
even though the dollar is not going up
per se what you will see is it starting
to explode against the things like the
Brazilian realitor Koosh lira
trafficking around all the weakest
borrowers have the problems first
explain the repo market they like how
does that fit in
the answer is I don't really know
because almost nobody knows we don't
know what's actually happening or we
don't know why it's happening we we
partly know why we've partly know what
but we don't know the whole picture okay
but what I'm hearing is that again it's
just changed again because the narrative
was you know we've just supplied the
Reaper market it was fine there was a
bit of stress on a few hedge fund
balance sheets and prime brokers and it
wasn't stress they couldn't get the
right funding levels and and various
issues with the inversion of the curve
creating a shortness and some technical
nature but it's just come screaming back
again in the last few days which
jpmorgan think wow we don't want to say
make it look like it's a bad thing so
we're gonna borrow money next minute
every banks you know something's going
on in the repo markets again and I think
there is a liquidity stress with some of
these larger hedge funds and I don't
know whether it's Citadel not meaning
they're necessarily losing money but
they can't get the money that they need
to pay whether it's it could be margin
calls but it could just be general
funding requirements yeah so again it
doesn't have to be catastrophic and I
don't I'm not I'm not one who buys into
the arguments that somebody's going
under it could be because Italy's
showing some stress it could be that
there's a problem deeper buried within
and I don't know what that well and I
don't think people understand how over
leveraged even hedge funds are right in
terms of some are some ons okay explain
so if you are somebody like and I'm just
using Citadel as an example because
they're not even really a hedge fund any
longer but they use huge amounts of
leverage to basically create price
liquidity because they're a market maker
and volatility in price in equities and
bonds in in whatever it may be
they're the marginal provider of
liquidity basically and there's several
other firms like them they also keep in
line all the arbitrage because the banks
don't have capital to trade this stuff
anymore
so they basically done what the bank's
did which is arbitrage the parts of the
curve and keep the money markets in line
with the euro dollar mark and the Fed
Funds marking to all of this stuff
problem is is if suddenly their funding
was then huge funding for there could be
hundred times levered
100 tonnes levered and they are that's
wild yeah and they are I don't know how
many billion dollars Citadel is as a
firm now and again I'm not picking on
Citadel have no idea but these firms are
have huge leverage because they're very
low risk but all of these have that risk
of picking up nickels in front of a
steamroller that some things can go
wrong so there is there is a problem
that could come from that they're very
smart people have the best systems in
the world the best risk management
they're exceptionally good at what they
do but if you just take the funding
level up by a few basis points screw it
all other P&L so it becomes a real
problem and then they start tipping out
risk yeah so your stress central bank's
a second ago and just mentioned funding
levels whatever we get close to these
periods they've got two tools sister
historically they can cut rates and they
can print more money we have obviously
seen them say that they're not printing
money in the quantitative easing sense
but balance sheets have expanded four
hundred billion or so over the last
couple of months we obviously just saw
the rate cut if you were running one of
these central max let's say the Federal
Reserve for example what do you do in
order to at least mitigate some of the
damage that appears to be coming if not
say I am NOT a buyer and belief that
central banks are evil okay I think
they're a function of the demographics
that they've been presented okay and yes
they've made some mistakes in terms of
creating for example part of the equity
market bubble I also think most of it
was driven by retirees or baby boomers
trying to save for retirement and and
the corporate tax break that allows
corporations to buy okay so I don't
think it's just to do with interest
rates of low I think interest rates are
low for a reason
I think growth has been the lowest this
cycle than any other cycle in all
recorded history I think that as baby
boomers move into retirement if you
think the relative marginal buying of a
25 year old and a relative marginal
buying of a six year old massive
difference so your marginal impact on
the economy Falls over time what happens
is it tends to slow economic growth and
we've seen it all over the world and the
closer you get to retirement or into
retirement
the less you spend so it has a big
lowering of growth so inflation Falls
with it yes and people say but my
inflation is not yes everyone's got a
different rate of inflation that's what
people have to realize you know okay
explain that a little bit more because I
think when people hear that they're like
what the hell is he talking about I did
this I wrote about it in global macro
investor and I said I took a bunch of
things and I said okay I'm gonna take a
pair of jeans I remember buying when I
was a kid and I'm gonna take the stereo
that I bought around the same time and
I'm gonna compare like for like and then
I'm gonna compare a different rate of
inflation for somebody else and I worked
out on a on a you know hourly earnings
adjusted basis just to get a
like-for-like so the pair of jeans that
I bought at the time and again I'm just
gonna come right now right about this
seven or eight years ago pair of jeans
important times thirty quid in the UK
and they were expensive designer jeans
you're stylin I was I was so pleased I
begged my mum for these jeans a pair of
Levi's about 20 okay so as a 50 cent
premium - apparently vice and Levi's
worth the standard Ching so you cut -
when I wrote the article I haven't
checked this and the stereo that I
bought it was a hundred pounds now I
lift a high-end stereo and it's a hind
quad stereo looks a couple of other
things anyway the point being is basic
goods was exactly the same price or less
so the Levi's were basically inflation
adjusted less the stereos were much less
what was interesting is the expensive
jeans were like five times more
expensive or ten times more expensive
and the high-end stereo was like ten
times more expensive so and what I'm
showing there was that if you were
slightly wealthier your rate of
inflation was about 15% or so on I
calculated
while the CPI of the same period would
have been about like - now for three
so different people now if I you're
saying different people is really you're
different you and I would be different
because we buy different types of goods
and those different types of goods
actually incur expectation our relative
our fixed cost basis that is the
important matter within this so
healthcare is a huge proportion of some
people's CPI right it's not a massive
proportion of my CPI but it's a huge
proportion of somebody else and so
that's why when they see inflation its
enormous for them when they see kids
school inflation University inflation
why University inflation why because we
have the second biggest generation of
people are all going to university at
the same time of course there's going to
be inflation they drove it you know so
different people have different
inflation rates and so I think the
notion the notion of a CPI is wrong and
I think you know the people who hate the
Fed for hiding the numbers I think it's
because everybody has a different CPI so
back to if you're sitting there near
Jerome Powell what do you do so go to
zero do we go to negative do we look
print a bunch of money there's a fair
argument that whatever they do makes no
difference now I have a feeling that
they will have to intervene and support
the pension system at the end of this
come a little closer than my sorry I
think they're going to have to support
the pension system at the end of this so
there is a lot of monetary printing to
come and it's a natural consequence of
the aging population and the promise is
given to it now just to clarify this is
rate cuts to zero plus the money
printing or are those two things
separate I don't think they have a
choice but to cut to zero everybody else
in the world is zero so Don Trump is
right you know it's it's an anomaly and
it's pointless
so cut it to zero no it's not going to
cause the stock market bubble because
we're in the middle of something much
bigger much more important so the issue
is then what happens
right in the only answer that we
currently have in a system that we
currently are given is fiscal stimulus
funded by government that by central
bank there is no other answer and this
gets us into if that money printing
occurs how does it get injected into
this gets a long story of how we get to
Bitcoin but caring yeah I'm dropping
breadcrumbs the whole way I can see so
we just lost in Hong Kong right for
those they don't know Hong Kong just
announced a 15 plus billion dollar
stimulus plan and in that they're gonna
give 7 million citizens give or take
about 10,000 Hong Kong dollars
1,200 bucks u.s. and what was
interesting is I've never seen this and
again you're you've been around but I
have her but ok well here's here's a
trick I learned
you're not older than me you're more
experienced than me but literally in the
headlines Cash Giveaway
the the Hong Kong government is doing a
cash giveaway it sounds like a [ __ ]
lottery but what they're doing is
they're handing the money to the people
rather than just injecting into the
system because the people who bring here
I mean they've locked up a home and
they've got agreed so fine and everyone
says helicopter money fine
let me tell you a story in Japan back in
1999 98 okay the Japanese wants to
stimulate their economy so I think it
was Paul Krugman and told them well one
of the best things to do was like I
can't remember the Krugerrand sayanora
give it to him but he was advised by
Western economists that the Japanese
revised my Western economists so what
you need to do is get long before QE
long before we even named it QE right
it's not worked never drove their
economy didn't help just kept things at
the margin taking over not imploding so
they decide to issue a voucher to I
think it was people of a certain age
can't remember the exact thing but they
were given a voucher that had a time
expiry on it okay I forced them to do
you use it they saved it interesting
it wait the people saved it or why human
behavior even with the time exploration
they still didn't like cash it in
yeah because they've been driven by you
know what had happened in the Asian
crisis well whatever it was so yes I had
some economic effect yes obviously some
people spent it but a much larger group
of people saved it than they ever
imagined and that's the other thing is
people talk about fiscal stimulus look
I've followed this in depth in Japan and
the Japanese put this fiscal stimulus
wave to calls the GBP goes straight back
down again
it doesn't work the only way you're
going to get fiscal stimulus to work is
completely rebuild an economy which is
why I take seriously the Green Deal
because that is a complete rebuild of
economy that could produce more
productive assets over time so in which
case you can do things like you know the
dams in America were built you know
anetha that is intelligent use a lot of
fiscal service doesn't go to intelligent
use so we saw this in the United States
back in I think was 2008 under George
Bush there was a $450 credit to
taxpayers yeah that's part of I think it
was a tarp bill or one of the bills yeah
we see it in Hong Kong today is that
just a natural kind of milestone that we
will get back to in the United States
where as we get cut rates to zero we
print a bunch of money there will be no
because we've always given color tax
relief or tax credit so I don't think
it's a big deal you don't need to big
deal okay
no what is a much bigger deal is when
you say right we've got a depression on
our hands the the emotional impact on
our population has been enormous how do
we create future
so what are you gonna do in that you
know you're going to rebuild systems
you're going to rebuild things and then
you're going to spend huge amounts of
money and you're going to print it to do
it that's really the what happens now
the the issue is is can the currency
system survive everybody doing that my
guess is no but if it maybe it can maybe
I'm wrong right but the point being is
that is a huge wave when everybody's
doing that at the same time it's much
bigger than a lot of the kind of
[ __ ] stuff that went into tarp so
that brings us to there's two groups of
people who historically have always
yelled and screamed about this well I
guess it's kind of like they're dreamed
not dream James is wrong word but their
predictions are looking more and more
probable every day in terms of hey you
can't print money forever you know it
creates these bubbles there's these huge
kind of negative cycles that occur and
that's the gold and Bitcoin crowd right
now I'm gonna to start put them in the
same crowd of just they have a very
specific yeah mistrusting and they
should have a very specific view of the
world they actually agree on the
problems for the most part they have
different answers as to what the
solution is you told me that your
portfolio you've got cash
you've got bonds gold and Bitcoin you're
in that group walk me through kind of
why I think all of it so there's a good
question because it will show you how I
try and think about things
so knowing this was coming because like
that allocations been around for a while
for me knowing this is coming my view
was that interest rates have to fall the
dollar because of the dollar issue is
going to rise it is going to create a
global wrecking ball that global
wrecking ball is going to cause
everybody to both stimulate massively
and so this pre Corona right there's
nothing to do with crow virus it's gonna
cause them to stimulate massively and
bail out their pension systems across
the world and that the outcomes of that
means that usually in that environment
gold does relatively well because
there's more fiat versus the value of
gold and it does work well if you look
at I look at gold in a basket versus a
basket twenty-seven currencies excluding
the US dollar okay it's just not the
dollar that's a driver and you can see
then gold is a currency basically and it
does exactly what suppose it goes up
trace I whisper it goes up yeah and it
goes up and it protects basically your
purchasing value as a global currency so
it is a global currency and works well
for that and so the the situation is
okay so we're now going to the point
where the dollars are wrecking ball and
there's a lot of printing money in gold
goes up okay that's a world we've kind
of lived in the last twenty years but
with the problem of the excesses of this
particular cycle and the the aging of
the baby boomers and leaving the
workforce and the retirement system I
think we have a chance of breaking it
having gone through nineteen ninety
breaking the system correct the
financial system is what I'm talking
about here and having gone through 2001
and and 2008 and seeing what's left of
the imbalances the corporate credit
being one and then how the system
doesn't actually function any longer and
a number of levels
the outcome is going to have to be a
move to something different you know if
there was anything that was genius about
the Satoshi whitepaper is basically
predicting this whatever whenever that
this comes right this is likely to be an
event now so I think of Bitcoin as a
call option on the outcome as his goals
a call option on
I'm has to be a change of the system we
got and that and that means the way I
look at this is basically 2:40 in I
think you are hitting right around this
which is we're headed to a bad situation
if the bad situation
hits kind of low to medium bad then gold
will do what it's always done Bitcoin is
likely to do similar to gold possibly it
yeah but just in terms of at least the
way that people are thinking about it
today today it's kind of digital cold
narrative if for some reason we don't
hit the load of mid bad levels and we
actually hit really really really
[ __ ] bad which is this kind of
breaking of the financial system gold
will serve as kind of a base case
protection Bitcoin is likely to then be
the thing that outperforms everything
because it is a resetting of the yeah
and it's also aside to that is an outer
that you'll be well aware of that most
people aren't really aware of because
there's too much talk about just about
Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
there is a brain drain of people coming
out of finance and coming out of
technology and coming out of science
that is beyond anything I've ever seen
in my life and they're basically
creating a hive mind to rebuild
financial custody ownership transfer of
everything world in parallel at the same
time and I don't care what tribe you
belong to whether you're a theory and or
Bitcoin or you know block one or anybody
they're all doing the same thing it is
the largest change that I've ever seen
and what it's incredible is we're it's a
hive mind doing it there's not being
directed by one person or one thing
everybody's working on different bits
the defy guys they're the transfer of
money there that this is you know Christ
I mean tokenization ours is taking the
technology that we have available to us
today and trying to literally rebuild a
financial system for an internet first
type world with in my opinion two key
differences the first is this idea of
separation of state and money and the
second is the
decentralization in a global manner
right and so the reason why I put those
two things there is I always think of it
as like the base unit of account and
then the infrastructure that is around
the financial services around it
historically when we've seen technology
in finance
it hasn't been anything to do with the
base unit of account right it's always
been around infrastructure around
services etc that's happening now and
there's this whole wave of that
occurring which kind of FinTech so not
even crypto really just FinTech and then
also that the crypto stuff but this idea
that the actual base unit of account
could change and is actually having in
it was you know only yeah I mean the
base unit account is having true
innovation right so and I've talked at
length about this like the Facebook
Libre thing was a really big moment and
we don't know how it's going to come out
in what form and there's it won't come
in full force at meanly but basically it
was a private company setting up an SDR
based on all the currencies in the world
including the US dollar so that basket
if you think of my gold basket 27
currencies this thing should move up and
down by global money supply right so
that's the most stable currency on earth
already and it's issued by private
corporation now what we also know is
every single central bank is building a
digital currency right so they're
building there's some admit it's some
deal but they're all done although in
India it's on ramps and off ramps they
get it so so they're building the
on-ramps are not off ramps the ability
of you to pay attacks is the ability for
them to control your use of currency
within casual societies oh yeah within
the state function but they also
understand there is no way of stopping
the other rise of other alternative
currencies and Facebook up said well we
can create anybody can create currency
now so you you're going into a different
world and currencies aren't what we know
as currencies because currencies can
have contracts embedded in them so that
is a whole grain mobile money yeah so
that is a whole different world of
everything but again I love the
visuality of like there's the old system
and it's driving itself into its buffers
at top speed we don't know when that
where we're going to hit that
all but we're gonna hit that wall
meanwhile it's like there's a whole
world being built can't parallel ya in
parallel and one day if there's a long
enough time you can basically just turn
the lights off on one and go to the
other you you of all people will
appreciate this recently I described a
Bitcoin as a parachute that's masked as
an adrenaline rush and it's kind of like
when you jump out of a plane right and
so it's exactly what you're talking
about is that parallel world that's
being built now the part to me that
really drives kind of my belief in
Bitcoin is that this is not a technology
problem right because just like you said
every central bank in the world is gonna
have a digital currency every
corporation that wants to is gonna issue
these digital currencies we see JP
Morgan in the bank so everybody's
talking about doing it so it's almost
like you get the the technology
horizontal comparison will be very very
similar if not almost exactly the same
to every currency in the world where the
difference lies or the true competition
is in the monetary policy all of the
central bank digital currencies have the
same monetary policy as their their fiat
counterparts right if you are Facebook
if you are JP Morgan whoever and you
create your own digital currency you're
still pegging it to a commodity or to a
currency so in essence you have a very
big separation there's basically bitcoin
which has this disinflationary monetary
schedule deflationary kind of structure
it's decentralized its programmatic
monetary policy kind of all the things
that we know that Bitcoin brings to the
table and it's true separation of state
money and then you have everything else
and everything else is a technology
quote-unquote innovation but it's the
same monetary policy that we have and so
the competition isn't going to end up
being on a technology standpoint it's
gonna end up being at that monetary
policy level and my bet is slowly and
then all at once we are going to see
people choosing the new monetary policy
over the old because they're gonna see
that old monetary policy for a lot of
cases you describe fail them
and when they see it fail them they're
gonna say well what else can I do
and so far we only see one serious
contender on the monetary policy
competition and it happens to be one
that you know looks like Bitcoin is this
kind of speculative asset today but
structurally is very very different than
what we've seen in the past yeah I think
that's right I think it is slowly and
then all at once and we're seeing it
like how many of our friends have got
involved how many people do we know in
that circle gets winder and you're not a
pariah now by saying I've got some
Bitcoin is it's common and it's not now
a sign of that frothy bubble because
even when the price has been doing and
not a lot there are more people coming
into the web people start to get it also
I just realized is you saw that China
was burning currency because of the
virus so I I have a I have said little
yes I've not tweeted this because I
don't want to kind of poke the the
beehive but there is an element of the
virus is showing that there is an
advantage to a cashless society and I'm
not gonna go as far as to say it's going
to accelerate the move there etc no but
China is burning literally pieces of
paper right to try to kill the fire to
spread the virus yeah and like six
months ago if we would have said that
people be like you're [ __ ] crazy and
again you know we talked about macro
before and how people look at today so
people like it look it's painful to open
an account is still painful most of the
applications are still not good enough
that everybody knows that and everyone's
working on it and there's a hive of
hundreds of thousands of people of very
very smart people all working on it
so the bet you have to take is will they
solve all of those things that make it
such an inconvenience to you today
because if if they will then the bet is
it will go up of course it's like I
wrote this thing but most people don't
see that they got one bitcoins not
usable that's not how you invest yeah I
wrote this thing at maybe a year ago now
where I basically went back and I took
screenshots of all the early web
companies so Amazon Google AOL you know
all these things in this example you
remember right I mean just atrocious
user experiences yeah the truest user
interfaces etc literally the AOL
dial-tone like I put the the recording
of the dial tone as you connected to a
well and little man ran across like I
was crazy stuff couldn't use your phone
at home if someone was on the internet
right all the stuff that at the time was
just that's how it is but the internet
was still powerful enough to get people
to do this now what we're seeing is the
exact same thing play out here with
Bitcoin and digital currencies and kind
of the whole whole digitization I mean
this you know one guy came to my office
the other day in the Cayman Islands and
he's building a decentralized data which
basically replaces AWS by using all of
the data abilities for Internet of
Things people's mobile phones and
creating supercomputers out of
distributed computing networks all right
you know and he's already good working
and it's working it's low cost and it's
super efficient and it means that all
the universities can crunch massive data
and have computing power that they could
never afford it's amazing and all of
this going on at the same time right I
think that's what people to understand
this digital revolution is not just
about the cryptocurrency it's about the
whole [ __ ] thing yeah and part of the
way that I think through this is what's
going on is people are rebuilding
existing systems but they're building it
now for a global digital world and what
I mean by that is historically companies
have let's say you start in the United
States you basically grew as much as you
could in the United States and and
everyone in the board room one year and
said next year is gonna be our big
internationally
expansion and you kind of went from you
know the domestic market to now we're
gonna go internationally and you spend
how much time and resources and hired
people and open offices and it all stuff
that's not the world we live in today
what today happens is when you start a
company your global on day one and
you're actually servicing users from all
over the world and so it's a very
different way of building a company but
what it also does is it drastically
affects the growth rate of these
businesses so if you compare you know
we've invested in businesses that look
very similar to an existing financial
services firm but one of it the
old-school way is domestic first and
then international expansion
these guys are global from day one they
actually are going after a much larger
market right in terms of the total
available users that they could have and
so on a percentage basis if you convert
the same number of people the aggregate
number of new users that you sign up is
you know sometimes five seven eight ten
times higher and so you get these growth
rates where companies are going from
non-existent to tens of millions of
dollars in revenue in two years three
years and I think that's part of what
people don't understand is it's not just
the technology it's not that there's a
lot of smart people it's that the
opportunity go from non-existent to
something that is mass I mean finance is
a great example right literally hundreds
of millions of dollars in revenue within
the first two years how do you do that
in the old world you can't right in this
world you can and now all of a sudden
you've got a well capitalized player
that's global because also when you
start something entirely from scratch
there are a bunch of different normal
profits mm-hmm right because if there's
a huge demand so we saw the internet
created supernormal profits and then
social media crazy supernormal profits
and this will create supernormal profits
for some yep so I mean the opportunity
is enormous I mean it's literally every
single person I'm in India what India
when fully digitized you know three
years ago unbelievable so here's a my my
favorite story about India I was there
when they did the D monetization I took
the 500
bill out etc right after that 18 months
later
India's RBI the central bank they're
banned they fight the legacy financial
organizations and banks from having any
relationship with crypto currency
exchanges services etc so they basically
said look your point of failure in the
crypto world is you're still relying on
a fiat traditional bank account
exception if we cut that off we're gonna
really hamper your ability to build the
Supreme Court literally this morning in
India just struck down that ban and said
you cannot discriminate the customer
base of these financial services firms
based on what industry they're in and so
now what just happened is basically the
entire India population can start using
those digital currency services
exchanges etc and also bring money from
their fiat bank account into that system
and you've seen that India rebuilt its
entire digital banking system right so I
can now buy milk with a fingerprint
mmm that's so pretty however crazes
right the they built without using
blockchain technology their own
technology for the ute ute IM i think
payment system which process is 50 times
faster than Bitcoin could back then when
it came out with you know failure rates
or no intermediary I mean I mean they've
got this thing called India stack and
you look the whole world's going this
way you know that there's quite a few
smart Indians I'm half half Indians I'm
half smart but there is India stack
India stack means that you can at a
digital layer now it's a government
layer and not distributed okay I get
that some people hate that whatever
that's not the point the point is or
you're kyc is in it
so their school sport so that for
everything you can now I mean you try
opening a bank captain India or a mobile
phone account you know in this
bureaucratic it's gone you can do it in
minutes you know try and do it here came
a nice wait when the bank counts
sometimes it's taking people three
months it's so onerous there you can do
it three minutes so India snack has all
of your documentation if you died your
medical records are there they know who
you are just by your fingerprint a
friend of mine from India just came here
and when we checked in downstairs at
security he pulled up this app and he
had his passport his driver's license
all this stuff in there and he showed it
to me and I was blown away by literally
in the u.s. would be the equivalent
having your birth certificate your
social security number your passport
your driver's license every you know
your insurance card all this stuff in a
single mobile verify that's verified by
the government that literally you just
tap two buttons and you can show it to
anybody they can scan it they can do
everything yeah it's crazy all right I
want to bring these two roles together
so there's the Bitcoin crypto world and
then there's the legacy issues that you
described I have been found you've been
pounding the table about bonds and and
everything for a while I've been
pounding the table that every public
pension in the United States should have
one percent exposure to Bitcoin as a
hedge depends on your age okay okay
explain why age because
the expected future return and the risk
profile don't match for a 65 year old
baby boomer because they have to divest
of assets then they need to own bonds
and I need to just understand that
they've got what they've got don't
speculate
now now here's my argument or counter to
that is they're not gonna earn a hundred
percent bonds right because that just
the way that the investment mandates are
of the pensions etc and so instead what
they can do is they can put one percent
allocation to a non correlated asset
with the value dry character I get the
theory why I just don't think it is if
you're the 65 year old what I don't
think the risk profile of the asset is
right for a 65 year old because the risk
profile of Bitcoin is the volatility of
the asset so they could probably take
some another asset with a potential
future expected return that is maybe
better I would take let's say VC because
you can invest in this space and I think
you'll have a better expected return for
those kind of people that vs. the
volatility right but younger you are the
more volatile you want the asset to be
but isn't the illiquidity of VC not a
good fit for a 65 year old as well yeah
I mean there was no there's no there's
no right answer and look you know as you
know I'm a huge fan of Bitcoin so it's
not it's not the issue of being a fan
I'm just a bit worried about putting
giving to my mum even at 1% yeah but it
doesn't really matter enough yeah and
not in the world we're coming in but the
real point is is anybody who has 10 20
years or less or more of working and
saving life and I've gone on about this
a lot religion is the answer to people's
younger people's future pension is
parthis is you have to have and I think
now is the time to take risk when you're
30
yeah what do you think that allocation
numbers is it 1% is it something much
larger much larger yeah 50 No
you thought about 50 for a second no I
think Kevin O'Leary yelled at me on CNBC
and he forbid me from 50% because he
said that's the stupidest thing he's
ever heard and then I had to ask him how
much of his portfolio was in equities
yeah yeah but you think the numbers I
think realistically if I think of the
future expected return of it let's say
and again we don't know but call the
press a million dollars right which is
the paper I wrote back in 2012 so it's
yes
so we're sort of a struggling around
eight ninety five hundred yeah yeah okay
so that's a pretty good risk reward
right it's already being the highest
performing asset of all time that I've
ever seen that I think ever record it
not hundreds that verified so that
expected return on a ten percent
allocation is simply life-changing for
anybody
it's basically a 1x downside 115 X it's
not 1x downside right it's probably what
okay well we're not absolute zero yeah
but even the chance of that invariably
but maybe goes down 90% okay so we'll
call it zero just to make the math easy
yep so basically can lose all the money
you put in you can lose 1800 X plus UPS
and make you could lose eighty five
hundred and make nine hundred and ninety
million
oh sorry nine hundred ninety thousand so
that's the that's the that's if it goes
up too if it goes up to a million from
its current price which do you think
that that is something that is realistic
would you put like how would you
handicap that let's say a million dollar
price point at this point given where we
are today and kind of how this has
played out well look in a portfolio it
doesn't matter what it has got a high
expected return I think it could be
worth much more than that and you know
in 20 years time we're talking about
SATs and not about
because that's just how we work and
actually that the divisibility of it
actually works pretty well it's just
changed our head set about using
decimals all time but that's that's how
it will be so doesn't really matter what
the price is but you've got at least for
an asset a 10x expected return at least
over what time period well even most
price projections would be you probably
do in ten years so you know ten x over
ten years I mean that's astonishing but
almost any asset price and the asset
class I've ever come across but it has a
chance of a bigger upside so that's just
how I think I also think my personal
point of view is that everything that we
know about investing is going to change
in whether Millennials will be doing it
but the Jen's II will is I think the
idea of a corporation goes and different
parts of a because a corporation is to
treat it as a single legal entities of
corporate as a person the point being is
that is now old-fashioned once you've
invented tokens because I can tokenize
Exxon in two maybe five thousand
different income streams asset prices
all of this so I can own any part of
Exxon that I want what an extraordinary
difference so you don't need to have
corporations that complex legal
structures but you can have different
types of a tokenization of this I think
the biggest change I think is going to
happen is for financial markets is
everything's gonna be tokenized yeah and
to understand tokenization and the
outcomes everything basically it's all
gonna be option theory and arbitrage and
what we're going to be finding is we're
going to be creating baskets of tokens
and we'll be looking at value baskets
and you know someone to mark you just go
about this a few weeks ago saying this
and you know the valley versus growth
all this you're gonna be doing all of
that in tokens yeah right now you know
everyone's discounts of half these
tokens they call them [ __ ] coins you
know anybody who's an investor should be
saying there is diamonds amongst all of
that yeah so I think this is a really
important point 99% of them are the [ __ ]
coins right because basically what you
end up getting is like in the
tokenization world so taking real assets
and tokenize them for example the first
people through the door are the ones who
they can't find buyers in the
traditional world they're not really
sexy yet or they're sexy assets from a
visual standpoint but the economics
don't really make sense
etc they're too high-priced there's all
these issues right and so they're the
first ones are always the ones that
aren't the most attractive and
definitely won't be the types of assets
in the steady-state what I think people
have to understand is you can't judge
the movement of two tokenization that
the kind of whole industry on the first
couple because if you do that what you
end up doing is you'll look at those
deals or assets you'll write off saying
these are bad deals these are bad assets
or they're not attractive assets from I
don't think anybody is going through
every single token and doing the work
and going to see companies and so right
what is the asset how does it work what
is your future expectation
expected returns what is the feature of
this cut nobody's doing that
no he's doing basic
yes on tokens and that is going to be a
revolution because that is coming and
that's what I'm saying is within all of
this as you say there's a bunch of
terrible ones there's ones that may have
a bet that is worth taking and there's
others that are the wrong price but
there's too many tokens because people
don't realize people are anchored on
tokens or currencies they're not they're
like a replacement to equities what
you're building is a new equity market
from scratch but based on tokens so the
S&P 500 will be the basket of voices
coinbase 500 token you know it's a
different world and they're not like
equities because they have all the
embedded components you want in it it
can be convertible it can be a bond
there could be an income stream there
can be an asset they can be a debt there
could be we have no idea that is the
flexibility and the incredible nasaw
what is coming so I don't think the
existing financial system really exists
because I don't think it needs to I
think it can change what is your if
you're comfortable saying what's your
percentage breakdown the portfolio of
cash bonds gold and Bitcoin I've always
been very cash heavy guy because I'm
actually quite risk-averse because you
take risk in your career so you don't
take risks in your personal life so I've
been very debt averse always and so I'm
Bitcoin I've I've never had a massive
allocation over under 10% under under
under hold
under 10 yeah just because it's not very
racy bitcoin I probably do more because
I'm quite early so I didn't really know
and then it came out and got back in
again and I probably did some more so
I'm just kind of re eyeing it at the
moment
bonds are huge leverage ok so because
I'm using them as a speculative trade
yeah and that's ok I'll go in and out of
that got it and dollars I mean I have my
head works in 2012 11 12 maybe 13 13 I
was living in Spain and the
Mediterranean coast
I was billing global macro investor in
Euros I was living in Euros my entire
life savings were in Euros and I woke up
and said the dollars going up and at one
forty eight and a half against the euro
I switched my billing all my personal
savings I then flew over to the US and I
ended up buying a place in Miami and the
place I didn't came and just stop myself
from from trading to turn it to keep it
in dollar assets and still have that
position today sound like me in Bitcoin
oh yeah I mean I just yeah I knew it was
the one trade is that bonds have been
basically at once right I mean I guess
what every pension I had to just turn a
whole lot of bombs years ago and just
left it that way you're one of the few
people I know that you were very very
bullish on Bitcoin at one point you not
lost some of the bullishness but but
basically said I don't know and then
went back to being bullish walk us
through just kind of mentally like that
journey yeah I mean journey is very
simple to me look and everyone has to
admit it you don't understand what this
thing is
we all think we understand we have no
real clue what this thing is
so when the fork started happening I'm
like I don't know I don't know what this
means mm-hmm and nobody did agreed we
didn't know the outcome was the outcome
but we didn't know and I said look I
don't understand this so I'm out
and I still I would have done the same
had I seen the same situation every time
again I've said I don't understand this
looks to me like you were diluting a
currency by creating identical
currencies now what what was amazing is
the adoption didn't happen so it was
almost like the market was offered the
ability to accept the dilution or not
and the market rejected it and actually
became stronger entrenched you know in
the original currency yeah amazing but
yes it did convince the mother stuff
like pick on cash and stuff that's out
there an interesting different use case
but really all of that forking was
didn't change I mean everyone she said
we don't care about the floors a Bitcoin
will just work on that and we'll work to
get around the floors hence the
Lightning L could network and all that
so that was that
and that was 2016 17 17 13 yeah 17 yeah
it was just before the price spike I got
out two and a half thousand or something
and I bought it two hundred so bad and
and then I walked away and then macro
happened from 2017 I could see what was
going on so I was very focused on that
bonds and currencies and it was Dan's
happy arrow who kept pestering me he he
has gone from I think not interested at
all to absolutely a [ __ ] animal on
Twitter
pushing the narrative so Dan said we
need to talk about this I'm like I look
down I'm I'm too busy with all of this
macro stuff and Dan's a macro gyrus I
really respect him and we know each
other well and you know he's a great
great great macro thinker
and so I said look we'll just do on
camera
we're still on religion that's this
easiest way because I'm going to do that
that crypts a week before the got no the
gold Bitcoin week so I said I'll do it
then because look you know I'd hadn't
had a conversation with Barry Silbert
that had got me very interested more in
digitization of stuff stuff online and
her digital stuff gonna have value in
them oh I'm starting to think about the
broader world again because I've always
been thinking about it's not like I
walked away from the whole concept I
walked away from Bitcoin for a bit cuz
it done somewhere it was but the whole
broader digitization world was moving
forwards in my narrative good
conversation with novo got me there so
then I sat down with Dan and I just
basically saw that the easiest way to
play this big story was basically
Bitcoin and so that was it I just got
back in the end yeah what do you think
about a decentralized finance aetherium
kind of the whole programmable money
yeah I love it all I just think it's a
different thing I think a theorem is
silver to gold's Bitcoin you know
because theorem has a somewhat of a
precious you know commodity element but
much more of a use industrial use
element like silver so I I'm very
bullish on ethereum I think got overly
built beat up because literally
everybody I know is building on a
theorem and again that will morph and
change in different places will get
different stuff and but so yeah I'm
extremely bullish on that before we get
into what's going on with real vision
presidential election does it matter who
the president is for where we're going
in the finance world I'm a fan of
neatness and for the neatness of the
narrow that one of the narratives that
followed which is the fourth turning by
Neil Howe I think it should have gone
far left
because the far-left will most likely to
break the system and change but no
changes like break corporatism break how
the healthcare system works break how
the financial system works right within
that that if you break the system then
you're creating the seeds of opportunity
for all of the things that we we think
can come
it's a innovators dilemma right you have
to disrupt yourself in order to actually
yeah and so I don't think that the
current rights of Trump is doing that
he'll disrupt some of the world trade
systems but the actual disruption of the
system itself is not going to come out
of him so if I believe in that for
turning narrative somebody has to break
it and now when you talk about breaking
it is this they're like anti capitalism
type Bluff it doesn't have to be and it
doesn't have to be anti capitalism it's
good anti kleptocracy and oligarchy okay
right it's how drug prices in America
are literally 20 times out of Spain he's
[ __ ] madness right it's illegal it's
price gouging and it's wrong it's how
it's it's the monopolistic power the
banking system the pension system how
you know they can have laws changing the
pension system to make sure it works for
the big financial services firms or the
the pension the asset management
industry that's wrong there's people's
you money it's wrong it's wrong
the oil companies and what they get away
with and what they should do and don't
do
you know there's so there's a number of
different things that I think people
would be pleased to see the back of
because everyone feels like we're being
disadvantaged and it's not capitalism I
think lives of Warren's point is
well-taken it's nothing to do with not
wanting capitalism what I don't want is
what I don't want is a system that gives
an inherent advantage to another person
got it
what's going on with real vision
revolution is amazing so lots going
often we've just come off that
retirement campaign cuz there's
something really really important for us
because this entire retirement narrative
is very big we have done a lot on this
you know we've been very early on this
coronavirus the economic impacts the
volatility stuff you know we've been
looking a lot this and we don't drive
that narrative per se just you know it's
our guests driving the narrative so
people have been coming well in advance
and that's usually how it works with
religion people go god those guys are
bearish and then all right they were
really right and it's not again I don't
drive that narrative I'm just one of the
contributors that appear on it so that
that's going on and then we've just
launched membership tiers which has been
a great thing for us because it was a
confusing journey where we had a
different product line macro insiders
and one called think-tank and then you
get the emails for that and so anyway
we've got this beautiful journey now you
come as a real vision member and you go
to religion plus where you get a lot of
these live broadcasts we get much more
to the you know timeliness more access
to our guests then we go into something
called Pro which is much deeper more
access and then we have something called
the blacklist the blacklist and yeah and
the blacklist is like a super-high-end
kind of concierge membership Club which
we have members all around the world and
we do these incredible events
I think your Scouts hosting one in Napa
next and next couple of weeks for a
bunch of these people so that's it
that's been really good so that whole
journeys been fantastic and then we also
launched as maybe people know we've now
got a free version that's on both our
website real vision calm and on YouTube
and we launched that I mean we've got
five million views in our first month
when we kind of went all like wow I've
known you views on YouTube yeah and it's
now settled at the moment about two
million views I'm gonna yeah wow that's
a lot well we went promoting it
it's came from nowhere yeah and while
you're taking the interviews and put
them on YouTube we were taking yet once
we started actually doing a bit of
effort with it but it's the same content
and we found that a long-form they died
interview content to actually would
that's just about to change our
benchmark interview is going to be our
free show so that interview will have
two of those out a week because we do
number of different formats we have
expert views blah blah but the the
interview will be free then we've built
a widget to embed on third-party
websites financial websites we're just
trying on Zero Hedge right now where
they embed the widget and relevant
videos are on the site the free videos
so to give us enormous scale in
distributing free videos because on the
other side we're working with corporate
partners by extracting Morgan Thomson
Reuters for affinity of whole bunch of
asset management firms and FinTech firms
creating videos for them and
distributing videos so we're doing a lot
of that work as well and that's really
you know a really exciting business with
a live events business going as well a
whole bunch of stuff so you know a lot
of people just know us for the video
channel that we've got a whole bunch of
stuff going around it we're we're we're
basically looking at the entire world's
financial world's pivot to video
everybody's moving to video it's a
revolution that's going on even your
podcast has gone to video you know
everything goes to video every financial
services firm has to go to video
everything that gets consumed is moving
to video videos like it's like the
spinning you know wheel of death it's
sucking everything into it and we're the
only people who really do what we do and
have a lot of experience doing it so all
the financial services firms have been
reaching out to us whether it's that
it's very high quality I'm a subscriber
I actually won't even let you guys give
me a comped
membership I tell her I'm [ __ ] pain so
I'm trying to give you the freeway so
expensive let's face it all you get it's
a hundred eighty eight the price no is
actually about to go up to 240 my guys
always gotta go he's got a pitch I love
it alright so one hundred eighty dollars
what is the real vision calm yeah right
and served Olaf a month trial right now
no-brainer that's a no-brainer yeah all
right what um what's the one thing that
you want people who is the average
investor the person whose hey look I
have a personal portfolio I've got you
know my savings a little bit of
investment capital etc what's the one
thing you think they should just tell
themselves over and over and over again
for the next 18 to 24 months cash is
king cash is king just for the average
guy right
don't overcomplicate it don't try and
beast and Rocco Miller don't try and be
the hero if you've got a bit of
speculative money that you want to bet
on the side to learn how this all works
fine do that there's some opportunities
and we've gone through them at length
here the reality is the best thing you
can have is cash yeah and the other
thing the other piece of advice that
helped me my whole life is if you ever
get in a situation where you can afford
to pay off your mortgage do that first
amongst all things because then nobody
can take anything away from you you have
a house to live in you can still work a
bar job you can do something and your
life is protected and working from a
position of strength is always better
than working from a position of weakness
a lot of people encrypt I don't like
Warren Buffett but he he's probably one
of the best if not the best investors in
our lifetime and right now he's sitting
140 billion in cash about a third of
their assets
let's tell you something right well
here's what I joke about all the time
when whenever anyone brings them up
these long Treasuries therefore right
yeah well it here's here's what the way
I look at it is forget the Bitcoin stuff
for a second right now I've ad nauseam
talked about how like you PI shouldn't
take technology advice from a guy who
doesn't use technology so I just put
that aside for a second going back to
your idea of doubling up and getting
super aggressive and having that risk
profile etc guys like him they salivate
over situations that we think are about
to play out because he's sitting there
with a bunch of cash all of these asset
prices are gonna drive down he's going
to make the rules and he's going to most
likely be able to drive incredible deals
for himself and for his shareholders and
the average person doesn't necessarily
have to be Warren Buffett but I think
your point about cash is king there's a
protection element to it but there's
also a lot of people right now who say
you know what I've got enough cash where
I want to buy an investment property I
want to do this I want to do that etc
it's probably going to pay off to be
patient yeah because things and even if
you don't have a lot of money they'll
say well what's the point of my 10 grand
you know what can I do with that
well guess what Paille the S&P 30% lower
is gonna be helped a lot well that's
gonna help a lot the other thing is
maybe you want to go on that trip around
the world well but the time coronavirus
goes those flights are going to be free
it's only free well that's right so you
know that whatever it is the ability to
have money when nobody else has it is
extremely powerful even as a small micro
level yeah yeah it's very fair real
vision calm what's your Twitter handle
that's Raul RA o UL GMI I'm about to go
back and need to write this I wrote
tweet this morning on the maths wrong
because I wrote it too early in the
morning yeah I'm just better put it out
it's quite shocking tweet about
comparing the virus to Spanish flu so
watch out for that as soon as I go back
to my hotel I'll do that and then I need
to go to the office and actually gonna
do real work to someone oh this has been
good all right you've been here for an
hour and 45 minutes you're a legend
I'm a huge fan of real vision obviously
you you nailed the the bond call there
and that was probably the best call of
my life he thinks I'm gonna give myself
for that path oh you know what a
question that somebody had yeah I got to
question for you before I let you go
what is the worst investment decision
you've ever made and what did you learn
from it no but like either you can
qualify worst as the stupid like your
psyche I've got or the amount I've got
me one of the good ones I bought I was
in London 2003 for and I decide that
Spanish property market looks good I've
already bought home that I'm a house our
house by start thinking that I want to
buy an investment property and on a golf
course because apparently that's what
people want but I [ __ ] hate golf it's
one of the worst things in earth with
the worst cultures I've ever come across
so I hate golf so I buy two apartments
on a golf course off plan because it was
near the house and of course now not
thinking through that really when people
come to the Mediterranean coast of Spain
the key is in the word coast and not in
a Golf Resort you know five miles from
the coast and so I bought them and I
thought yeah I'll just rent them out
because there's all these golfers
that'll do that
obviously everybody thought of doing the
same thing at the same time in Spain and
by the time the apartments were
completed about 2006 great timing I can
rent them there so 2005 maybe I couldn't
let them so the the implied yield at
home my hair does like look at me smart
I'm a hedge fund guy I've just bought
these BOTS you know I'll get a 5% 7%
yield any way I'll just carry it and
it'll be fine and then over time the
price will appreciate just couldn't rent
them at all and then I ended up
selling both of them for the same price
I paid one of them because I think just
because I just wanted to get rid of the
damn things because I hated them so much
because I didn't like golf their
apartment that I would never use myself
they were but that's gonna happen a lot
I think of next 24 months yes and
because a lot of no idea about that is I
made an investment something I shouldn't
have made an investment in mmm-hmm you
know there's certain things I couldn't
there's other property I could have
invested in that it wouldn't have made
such a stupid mistake is something I
couldn't rent and couldn't sell him he
was on the market for three years trying
to sell out four years trying to sell it
when the whole of Spanish property was
offered only most important book and
luckily I didn't have a mortgage as if
I'd had debt then I'm screwed
most important book you ever read most
important
bonfire of the vanities why because it
is the that's not I'd say today and so
different answer tomorrow because it is
it shows the humility that we all have
to have when we all think we're geniuses
are amazing for whatever reason that we
do that narrative that we have our
vanities everyone has to realize they're
not real as for that humility in all
things is actually what you should
strive to achieve for without it being
your defining factor oh he's so humble
because usually that's like your fake
last question that you get asked me a
question we're done aliens you believer
if I like if I believe in probabilities
then of course why well just because
permutations and combinations are
infinite so therefore there's infant
outcomes so of course that's fair just a
math equation it's just a math equation
yeah I agree
you know it's it's not difficult the
question all started I have asked over
Turner people this now because I was
laying in bed one day and I thought
everyone always asked about aliens but
you know there's intricacies to life and
so here on earth we have pets
- there's humans and animals do you
think there's like alien pets you think
that they're walking around and they've
literally like domesticated other but
all pets pets
or is this a symbiotic relationship
where they are using us you're going
down the rabbit hole that's exactly why
I asked the question what question you
got for me to finish up when it's the
next time you're gonna get a plane oh
man
so alright when do you actually think
you'll fly again okay so you'll love
this last year did a hundred twenty
flights I think and told myself I'm not
gonna travel this year I had to go to a
board meeting in San Francisco in I
think it was January end of January I've
never in my life
bought a mask I've never worn a mask
I've never done anything I got on the
plane and I couldn't find in 95 masks
they were all sold out here in New York
so I literally was like what else can i
buy well I'll just buy a [ __ ] dust
mask I guess whatever I can get them
really do anything
put it on had a hood pulled it real
tight and I literally sat there with
like my hand sanitizer in my hand I was
like the the germaphobe of the year
right cuz I just freaked out I just
didn't understand it whatever flew back
I have since taken two more trips so I'm
on three trips for the year I'm supposed
to go at the end of March back to San
Francisco next week I'm supposed to go
to DC made all these things I'm
seriously considering just saying I'm
not going anywhere I'm not I'm going
back to Cayman and I'm not this kind of
guy I'm not a prayer yeah just not the
guy I'm usually a risk taker when it
comes to this don't give a [ __ ] I like
going to war zones you know I really I
don't mind I'm gonna matter Cayman and
I'm not I was supposed to be going to
Napa Valley to the to something in March
not going I'm a global Mac investor
round table in Majorca I've canceled it
I'm supposed to be spending a month in
the summer in Italy and Spain okay
yeah just because I don't know yeah and
the outcomes aren't quite I don't want
to be again I been ill that's not the
thing that I fear it's being suddenly
then not be able to get home that's a
one serious issue right if you get
quarantined the other thing is I live in
a country as a foreigner now let's you
back there mind let us back they might
throw us out because the medical system
can't deal with us there's a whole lot
of unknowns that is really complicated
so I yeah I just I don't know the
answers real vision dot-com go subscribe
Allison's happier than it it's not
always like this role is is a legend
thank you so much for doing this I
thoroughly enjoyed it all those a bit
apocalypse